젠슨이 지금 타이페이
하는 그 GTC26이라는 행사를
해요. 그래서 대부분 대만 들렸다가
중국 들렸다가 원래 미국에 돌아갔는데
이번에는 또 한국에 온다라는 소식이
전해졌습니다. 한국 괜히 오겠어?
어, 누구 다 만나고 가지 않겠어라는
기대감이 커졌는데 그래서 누구 만나
찾아봤더니 최태원 회장, 정의선
회장, 구광모 회장과의 만남이
예정되어 있다라는 보도가
전해졌고요.이 중에서도 왜 LG가 더
강한데라고 여쭤 보신다면 국광무
회장과 어, 젠슨이 만나는 건
처음으로 알려져 있습니다. 그전에음
그 젠슨왕의 딸이 LG 그룹과의
접촉이 있긴 했었는데 그러면 그때
얘기 끝내고 뭔가 마침표 찍으러 오는
거 아니야라는 기대감 때문에 급등을
하고 있다라고 보시면 되겠고요.
거기다가 AG 그룹주가 어 찬찬히
살펴봤더니 아니이 친구들이 로봇 밸류
체인을 다 갖고 있네라고 평가받으면서
관련된 종목들이 급등하고 있습니다.
제가 표로 좀 정리를 해 왔는데요.
LG 전자 같은 경우는 액추에이터
그러니까 관절 같은 거 만든다라고
보시면 되겠고 LG CNS 같은
경우는 쉽게 이야기하면은 클라우드
서비스 로봇 플랫폼을 할 수
있습니다. LG 이노텍이 반도체
기판만 하는 줄 아셨겠지만 카메라
모듈과 로봇 시각 센싱도 할 수
있거든요. 로봇도 봐야 뭘 할 거
아니에요.
디스플레이로봇에
디스플레이가플러스가
갑자기냐 하실 수도 있겠습니다만 어
로봇이 AI를 탑재하려면 통신이 왔다
갔다 해야 돼요. 예. 그래서 거기도
있고 LG 에너지 솔루션 같은 경우는
로봇에 배터리 들어갈 수 있는 거 뭐
선 꽂아서 쓸 순 없으니까. 그리고
로보티즈와 로보스타 같은 경우는
LG가 지분을 갖고 있다. 그래서
이렇게 쭉 밸류 체인을 구축하고
있다라고 하면서 강세 보입니다.
>> 어쨌든 젠슨왕이 만난다면 지금 뭐
주가가 오르는 거잖아요.
>> 근데 과거에도 그랬고 뭐 깐부
해동이라고 할까요? 그 이후로 어쨌든
SK하이닉스도 크게 상승했고 삼성도
주목을 받았으니까
>> 주자들이 관심을 갖는 건 뭐 당연해
보입니다. 또 하나 더해서 LG
관련된 그 회사들이
>> 워낙 주식 시장에서 좀 소회를
받았잖아요. 그래서 이런 작은 뭐 큰
뉴스지만
>> 뉴스에도 반응 속도가 빠른 거 같아.
>> 음음. 그동안에 수급이 많지 않았기
때문에
>> 근데 전 이런 걸 보면서 저 그냥
너무 그렇게 바라보지 마시고 대한민국
너무 대단하다 그렇지 않습니까?
>> 왜냐면 못 하는게 없어요. 어 이제
로봇 눈도 다 만들어요.
>> 이런 나라가 어디어 눈도 만들지 팔도
만들지 관전도 만들지 발도 만들지
그다음에 그 머릿속에 있는 거 다
만들지 이런 나라가 있습니까?
>> 그러니까 젠순왕도 이렇게 대한민국
와서 치킨 먹고 그러는 거 아니에요.
>> 이번에는 어느 치킨집이요?
아, 그걸 경쟁해야 되겠네.
>> 그 아니 깜부 치킨은 상장이 안 돼
있어요.
>> 네, 상장 안 되어 있고 재미로
말씀드리면 깜부 치킨 회동 다음날
치킨 관련주가 오르게 됐습니다. 진짜
>> 어디서 만나냐 같은 또
>> 아, 그러면 이번에 뭐 예를 들면
족발집 가면 족발도 모르겠네 뭐 이런
식이에요.
>> 네. 그러니까 지금 어제순왕 온다는
기사가 떴는데 이게 중요해요,
여러분. 기사 잘 읽는 법, 또
애널리스트 잘 보는 법. 이것도
우리가 살짝 말씀드렸는데
>> 기사 잘 읽는 법을 보면 진순한 방안
좋다 이거야.
>> 음.
>> 바로 헤드라인이 LG 구강모 네이버
만난다. 이게 헤드라인이에요. 뭐지?
예. 얘네들이 흘린 거죠.
>> 우리야. 우리 우리 저요? 저 저
만나요. 예. 그겁니다.
>> 예. 그래서 자세히 제가 들어가고
봤는데 그때 만난다고 할 때 뭐
무슨무슨 회사는 뭐와 제스러운 관계가
있다 이렇게 기사 쭉 나왔더라고요.
>> 예. 근데 이제 어차피 지난 기사니까
기사 처음 딱 볼 때 어 왜 LG
CNS가 빠졌지? 기사에는 없었어요.
빠
>> 아니 얘네들 진짜 홍보를 왜 이렇게
하는 거야?
>> 어 당연히 넣었어. 넣어서 보도자료
뿌렸어야지. 네같진
LG는 진홍보 너무 못한다 이런 생각
했었거든요. 내용은 좋은데 늘 마케팅
못한다고 욕걸 먹잖아요. 근데 시장이
더 현명한 거지.
>> 스가 오늘 상한가 갔어요. 그니까
투자자분들이이
체인을 딱 보고 그냥 바로 찍은
거죠. 예. 그런데 이제 네이버도 어
만나는 거죠.
>> 네. 맞습니다. 네이버도 만든다.
만난다라고.
>> 아 근데 문제가 있어요. 이렇게
뉴스에 오르면 사야 돼요. 빨아야
돼요.
>> 어 고민되죠.
>> 고민되죠.
>> 네. 야, 이게
>> 그니까 내용이 있을 것 같다. 아까
이제 권역님 말씀처럼 이미 딸이랑 몇
번 만났고 모종에 협의가 좀 있었던
거 같은데 혹시 이번에 중요한 발표가
나오나 적어도 그다음을 기약할 수
있는가 있나
>> 어 뭐가 나오면서 맞춤 표가 찍히는
건가 뭐 이런 거를 기대할 수 있으면
뭐 따라가도 좋고
>> 어 그냥 만나는 거면 뭐
>> 근데 전 뭐 따라가든 사든 뭐든 그건
이제 결정입니다. 열정인데 대신 이런
변동성이 큰 주식 그니까
변동성이라는게 나쁘다는 의미를 드리는
건 아니고 어쨌든 뉴스에 크게
움직이는 주식은 마찬가지로 계획이
당연히 있어야 돼요. 그래서 주가가
과도하게 뭐 뉴스가 반영 안 되거나
잘못된 뉴스가 빠지면 계속 들고
가서는 안 된다. 그리고 예를 들어서
좋은 뉴스가 나와서 오르면 들고 가면
되잖아요. 그래서 여러분들이 아,
나는 사는 거의 목적이 물론 사는
거의 목적이 있지만 사서 어떻게 할
건지에 대한 계획도 함께 세워
보셨으면 좋겠다는 말씀을 드립니다.
맞습니다.
안녕하세요. 여러분의 밥 친구가 되고
싶은 12시에 만나요. 이광수입니다.
신나는 월요일인데요. 또 기분 좋게
주의 시장도 상승해서 출발하고
있습니다. 근데 오늘 상수이 생각보다
굉장히 큰 거 같습니다. 삼성전자가
주로 시장을 이끌고 있고요. 어 기타
또 주요한 어 우리나라 기업들이
주가가 상승하고 있습니다. 주가가
오르면 좋은 거죠. 박실 대표님?
>> 그렇죠.
확도로는데 깜짝 놀랐는 얘기죠.
모르면 좋은 거죠. 예.
>> 근데 주식 없는 사람들 어떻게해요?
>> 그러니까 그게 문제입니다.
>> 예. 이런 국면에서 사실은 이제에
포물을 느끼시는 분들 많고요. 또
이제
>> 어 아예 없거나
>> 이제 있는데 코스닥이라든지 내 종목은
안 올라 이런 분들이 많아요. 오늘도
사실은 오르는 종목보다 안 오른
종목이
>> 하락하는 종목
>> 하락하는 종목이 훨씬 많아서 예 좀
>> 아 나는이 장세에서 소유되고 있다.
이런 분들이 또 생각보다 많습니다.
예.
>> 그래서 저희가 할 일이 많아요.
>> 네. 많은 분들이 어이 상승을 좀
즐기고 나눴으면 좋겠는데
>> 장세 자체가 그렇지 않게 흘러가고
있고 근데 이게 잘못됐다는
저는 사실 아닌 거 같기는 해서
>> 예 그래서 투자 전략을 잘 세우실 수
있도록 저희가 많은 도움을 드려야
되겠죠. 그니까 지금 말씀하시는게
굉장히 중요한데
>> 내가 여기에 일종에 다른 방향으로
가고 있으면
>> 나하고 다른 현상이 나타났을 때 그걸
비난하고 잘못됐다고 생각하고 아 그건
언젠가는 꺼지겠지
>> 그건 아닌 거 같아요.
>> 예. 이거 지금 우리나라만 이렇지
않거든요. 미국도 사상 최고치였는데
정거래 금요일 마감 때 하락 종목이
더 많았습니다.
>> 이거 일본도 그렇고요. 대만도
그렇고요. 사실은 다 똑같이
올라갑니다.
>> 그렇죠. AI 시대를 대표로 해서
어쨌든 큰 시장의 변화, 새로운
시대가 열리고 있는데 그 시대에 맞춘
종목들이 이제 오르고 있는 거죠.
그래서 잠깐 한번 보실까요? 상승
하락 종목만 한번 보여 주실래요?
네. 네. 상승 하락 종목수 함께
보도록 하겠습니다. 코스피에서 오르는
종목이 193개고요.
빠지는 종목이 722개.
코스닥에서는
하락 종목이 1500개에 육박하고
있고요. 오르는 종목이 220여개
밖에 되지 않습니다.
>> 오늘 현황이고 저건 제가 최근 한
달간 코스피 코스닥의 주가 변동
종목수를 한번 조사해 본 겁니다.
쉽게 말해서 지수가 계속 오르고
있는데 13% 밖에 상승한 종목이
없어요.
>> 네.
어 근데 다시 말씀드리지만 여러분들이
저걸 보면서 버블이다. 막 우리 시장
잘못됐다 이런게 뭐 어 뭐 아니다라고
판단하시는 건 아니라는 말씀을 드리는
거예요.
>> 맞아요.
>> 이제 시장을에서 이제 유행이랄까
트렌드가 딱 잡혔는데 굳이이 그거를
뭐 거부하거나
상황이 아니고요. 그 트렌드나이
흐름에 사실 맞추는 것도 지금 굉장히
필요하고요. 지금은 특히 이제이 이런
유행 소위 말하는 이제 AI 관련한
주도주들 위주로 일단 집중화가
확실하게 지금 잡혔기 때문에 여기서
지금 잘못 이제 전략을 잘못 세우거나
시장과 다른 방향으로 가면서 아니야
내 선택이 오라 기다릴 거야 이렇게
하기보다는 지금은 철저하게 시장
수능적으로 전략을 다시 세우셔야 될
>> 답니다. 그니까 유행을 잘 쫓아가는게
힘든 힘든가 봐요.
>> 아니요. 그렇게 해야 되는데
>> 이제 고집이죠. 사실은
예 아니야. 이건 분명히 내 제적
가치가 좋아. 오를 거야. 음속는
>> 지금은 이제 조금 심한 말씀드린다면
고집부릴 때 아니고 이미 잡힌 시장에
유행 트렌드에 수능하면서 투자해야
된다. 전략을 그쪽으로 올 맞추셔야
된다. 이런 말씀드립니다.
>> 꼭 명심해야 될게 내가 시장을 움직일
수가 없어요.
>> 아 그럼요.
>> 그래서 말씀하신 것처럼 고집을
피우거나 내가 생각이 오라 이렇게
할게 아니다. 투자는 그래야 돼요.
생핏
우리 형님도 계속 얘기하는 거
아닙니까?
>> 뭐라 그랬습니까? 또
>> 내가 잘못한 정 많다.
>> 아 인정하잖아요.
>> 그렇죠. 그죠 유연하게 생각하고.
>> 예
>> 좋습니다. 오늘 주시장 정리를 해
볼까요?네 네, 지수부터 보도록
하겠습니다. 지금 12시 4분
기준으로 코스피는 4.5%대
강세입니다. 8,860선 지나가고
있고요. 오늘 참 대단하다고 느끼는게
매수 사이드 카가 11시 30분에
걸렸습니다. 원래 매수 사이드 카
같은 것들은 거의 장 초반에 걸리는데
오늘 굉장히 강한 시장이 지금
정호까지도 이어지고 있습니다. 하지만
코스닥 같은 경우는 현재 2%대
하락합니다. 150선 지나가면서
오늘도 온도차는 일어나고 있습니다.
또 수출 지표도 좋았고 지수도
오르는데 외국인의 매도는 오늘도
이어지고 있습니다. 현재 2조원
가까이 매도를 하게 되면서 환율의
오음새가 체크가 됩니다. 1516원대
지나가고 있고요. 근데 이거는음
우리나라만의 문제라기보다는 구조적인
문제 같습니다. 현재 일본 같은
경우는 159엔 넘어서는 환율을
보여주고 있어서 함께 따라간다라고
보시면 되겠습니다. 뉴스들 한 가지씩
보시죠. 아, 저희가 지금 사상
최고치 6,800선이라고 써 놨는데
무색하게도 8,800을 넘어가고 있는
코스피입니다. 상승하는 여러 가지
이유가 있겠습니다만 5월 수출액 역대
최고치였다라는
소식과 함께 급등하고 있습니다. 두
번째 뉴스입니다. 젠슨 황이음
이제 시작을 했겠네요. 지금 어
대만에서
어 시작했네요. GTC 2026
타이페이 키노트 연설을 하고
있습니다. 데이 키노트 연설 끝나고
나서 한국으로 오게 되죠. 삼성,
SK 현대차 네이버와 타이페이에서
만찬을 한다라고 합니다. 오늘 행사
끝나고 내용 살펴보도록 하겠습니다.
오늘 삼성전자가 실가 총액 2,조원을
넘겨냈습니다. 현재도 9.7%대
7%대 강세로 34만8,000원 선
지나가고 있는데요. 로봇 조직을
무언가 하나로 모은다라는 소식이
전해지면서 강한 탄력 받아가고
있습니다.네 번째로는 가운 전선을
필도로 오늘 전선 전력 설비 관련된
종목들이 올라가고 있습니다. 구글,
아마존, 메타의 AI 센터 부품 수주
소식과 함께 어 오랜만에 오르고
있는데요. 흐름들 살펴보도록
하겠습니다. 지금까지 정호의 머니
뉴스였습니다.네
>> 감사합니다. 코스피 지수가 이제
9천을 앞두고 있어요.
>> 그러니까요.
>> 아, 이건 정말
>> 9천 뭐 엎어지면 코달할 때예요,
이제.
>> 그러니까요.
>> 예. 9천으로 가는 건 아니죠.
>> 네. 죄송합니다.
죄송합니다.
>> 어떻게 뭐 저 레드 카드 아니 한
거랑 카드 좀 합니다.
>> 옐로 카드 하나 뽑고 있어야 될까요?
>> 아재개그 금지.
>> 예. 죄송합니다.
>> 야, 이게만을 이제 앞두고 있어요.
>> 네.
>> 어, 어떻게 보세요?
>> 어.
만은 뭐 충분하다.
>> 만까지 한 10% 10 5% 14%이
오지 않나요, 지금? 거의
9천이니까. 네. 10%만 가면
많이해요. 네. 예. 예.
>> 일단 오늘 그 8,800 거의 뭐
8,900까지 가까이 올라가고
있는데요.
>> 오늘 상승의 뗄감
>> 모멘텀 뭘까요? 예,
>> 오늘 수출 지표가 발표가 됐습니다.
>> 수출 가장 중요한 지표가 오늘
나왔습니다.
>> 네. 이제 6월 1일이니까 5월치
수출을 정리를 해서 발표가 됐는데요.
전체 5월 수출 877억 달러로 역대
최대였습니다.
반도체 수출 초호항에 힘입었다라고
했고요.이 5월 수출액 877억
5천만 달러는 전년 전년 동기 대비
53% 늘어난 숫자로 역대 최대
실적이라고 합니다. 반도체 수출 같은
경우는 전년 동기 대비 169%
증가하면서 371억
5천만 달러, 3개월 연속으로
300억 달러 웃돌면서 역대 최대
수출이라고 합니다.
>> 일단 주가가 오르는 이유가
명확합니다. 대한민국이 수출이
증가하고 있고요. 오늘 삼성전자가
오르는 이유도 어 분명합니다. 반도체
수출이 371억 달러를 기록해서 역대
최고치예요. 네. 근데 제가이
수치로이 수출 금액으로 그리고 어
메모리 반도체 가격 상승부를 감안해서
추정해 봤더니 2분기 삼성전자 영업
이익이요네.가
>> 100조원이 가능해 보입니다.
>> 100조요. 와
>> 분기예요. 100조원이에요.
>> 분기 분기
>> 1분기에 57조원이었거든요.
57조였죠. 57조원이 100조가
된다는 얘기거든요.
>> 근데 이게 아 제가 지금 다시 열어
보니까 삼성전자의 분기 영업이
컨센서스 그러니까 시장에서 예상하는
평균치가 85조거든요. 근데 아마
오늘로 더 올라가게 되겠죠. 근데
연간이 이미
>> 지금 350조예요.
>> 근데 분기가 85조인데 연간이
350조다.
>> 올라간.
>> 더 올라가요.
>> 그러면 거의 400조가 근접해 갈 수
있다는 거. 연간으로 400조를다.
>> 네.
>> 이게 상상이 됩니까?
>> un빌리버able입니다. 진짜로
>> 상상조차 안 해본 가보지 않았던 길은
당연하고요.
>> 혹시나 갈 수 있을까라고 상상조차 안
해본즉 그야말로 전인 미답기를 가고
있습니다.
>> 네.
>> 아, 이런 수치는 근데 더 놀랄
만한게 이번에 가격이 계속 오르고
있다는 거예요. 어, 그러니까 지금
반도체 가격이 메모리 반도체 가격이
5월만 해서
>> 네. 25%가 올랐어요.
>> 네.
>> 놀랄 만한가 한 달 만에 25%가 또
올라요. 그죠?
>> 그니까 전 달 대비인 거잖아요.
>> 네. 그리고 랜드 같은 경우는
10%가 떠오르거든요.
>> 네.
>> 와, 이거는 그러니까 다시
말씀드리지만
그니까 매출이 증가하는데 가격이
올라서 매출이 증가하기 때문에 이거는
고수라는 이익으로 올 거예요. 그죠?
그래서 제가 예측하는데 삼성전자의
2분기 예를 들어서 에스카닉스
비슷하게 영업 이익률이 80%를 넘을
겁니다.
>> 이렇게 가격이 계속 오르네.
>> 네. 80%예요. 이거는 보기
김선달이에요.
어
>> 그러니까요.
>> 그냥 대동강 물퍼도 지금 팔고 있는
거예요.
>> 맞습니다.
>> 예.
>> 이런
>> 제가
>> 네.
>> 이런 회사를 본 적이 없어요.
역사상.
>> 맞습니다. 예.
>> 있을 수가 없는 일이 일어나고 있다.
>> 네. 그러니까 이제 저희가 모두의
인사 말씀드렸던 거랑 지금 맥을 다
함께 하는 건데요. 우리
투자자분들께서 쟤네들 무슨 얘기 하고
있는 거지?이 근저 흐르는이
>> 핵심적인 아이디어를 좀 같이 공감해
주셨으면 좋겠는데요.
>> 아, 가보자 하는 길을 지금 코스피가
도달하고 있고 왜 이렇게 지수가 많이
올라?
>> 그 무겁다는 삼성전자가 지금 10%가
오르고 있어요. 왜 올라? 뚜껑을
열어보니까 예, 아직 분기 실적은 안
나왔습니다만은 월간 실적으로 나라에서
실적을 냈는데 반도체가 또 역대급
수출을 내고 있고 국제적으로 가격을
우린 실시간으로 볼 수 있거든요.
그걸 봤더니 가격도 지금 계속 오르고
있고 이거를 5월 달 것까지 그래서
4월 달, 5월 달 거 나왔으니까
이제 6월 달 한 달만 더 넣으면
되거든요. 6월 달가까지 합쳐서 이제
삼성의 2분기 실적을 예상해 보면
예, 전분기가 57조인데 지금
100조는 걷든이 가능하다라는
거예요. 그럼 연간으로 합치면
400조도 지금 충분히 도달 가능한
상황으로 보인다라는 거죠.
>> 하이닉스 마찬가지고요. 네. 그니까
이런 상황으로 놓고 보면 아 돈을
천학적으로 지금 지구에 있는 전
전구적으로 돈을 쓸어담고 있는데 이런
회사의 주가에 애가 오르는 거
자연스러운 거고요. 여기에 집중되는
현상 꺾일 리가 없어요. 지금은
예.이 맥락을 좀 깊이 있게 이해해
보시면 될 거 같아요.맞.
>> 트렌드포스에서
주말 동안 메모리 시장 전망치를 엄청
올려줬어요.
>> 네. 26년에
기존에는 5,억 달러 수준일 거라고
했는데 8,893억
달러로 올려줬어요.
>> 그러니까요.
>> 그리고 27년에는 기존에는
8,427억이었는데요.
>> 네.
>> 메모리 시장이 1조 달러가 넘어갈
거다. 1조 2,800억 달러가 될
거다라고 해서 전년 동기 대비 44%
이상의 성장을 보일 거다라고 이야기를
했습니다.
>> 네. 올해는 전년 대비 지금 296%
맞습니다. 네. 그러니까 저게 이제
잘 보셔야 되는게 뭐냐면 메모리
반도체를 더 이상 저만큼 많이 생산해
낸다는게 아니에요.
>> 가격이 올라서 시장이 커진다는
거예요. 그러니까 지금 케파가 공장을
짓고 있기 때문에 그리고 많이 짓지
않고 있기 때문에 갑자기 막 생산력이
증가할 수가 없거든요.
>> 그런데 저렇게 규모가 커진다는 건
그럼 가격이 그만큼 오른다는 거예요.
>> 네. 그렇습니다. 그렇습니다.
>> 네. 그래서 저희가 장기 예전에
메모리 가격 한번 그려 드렸잖아요.
갑자기 확 올라가는 걸 보면서
사람들은 일시적일 거야 생각하는데 더
장기적이고 보니까 얼마 안 됐다.이
말이 말 제가 했어요, 안 했어요?
>> 그렇죠.
>> 했잖아.
>> 우리라도 인정해 주지.
>> 그 그래프 한번 찾아보세요. 반도체
장기 그래프 애전보. 그러니까 이게
어쩌면 다시 한번 말씀드리지만 새로운
시대를 이거 말고 예전에 그게 이렇게
한번 그려 드린게 있는데 혹시나 찾을
수 있으면 띄워봐 주세요. 예네.
>> 저희가 이런 새로운 시대를 맞이하는
어떤 자세에 대해서 이제 한번
말씀드린 거 있는데
>> 어 너무 가가파르게 상승하니까
사람들은 야 이건 일시적인 거야,
거울이야. 이렇게 얘기하는데 또 다른
사람들은 그렇죠.이 그래프요. 어
보시면
>> 저걸 보면서 야 저렇게 그래프가 우뚝
썼는데 저게 더 오르겠냐? 이렇게
얘기한단 말이죠. 그런데 길게
보세요. 2000년대 초반에는 훨씬
더 가격이 올랐어요. 비쌌어요.
>> 그러면은
>> 어 이런 생각을 좀 해 보는 거죠.
어 저렇게 오를 수도 있는 건가?
>> 그렇게 되면 이익이 또 두 세 배
증가하는 겁니다. 어
>> 네. 그리고 지금 뭐 삼성 화이닉스만
야 너네 너무 우리나라 회사에서만
소위 국봉으로 가는 거 아니야? 그
상황이 아니고요. 마이크론 얘기도
잠깐 해 주시죠.
>> 네. 마이크론에 대한 목표 주가가
계속해서 오른다라는 말씀은 드렸었죠.
뭐 마이크론 테크놀로지는 삼성전자
SK 하이닉스 그리고 아 마이크론까지
3대 메모리 업체라고 말씀드릴 수
있고요. 지금 주가가 어마어마하게
올라가고 있거든요. 그 친구도 근데
지금 대장이라고 해서 미국 시장 이제
마감하고 나서 미국 거의 24시간
거래가 되잖아요. A장에서 지금
1,000달러를 돌파한 것으로 확인.
>> 마이크론도 지금 저희가 지난주에 살짝
말씀드렸는데
>> 지금 그 UBS에서 예. 목표 기존에
있던 목표가를 세배를 올렸어요.
그러면서 잡은게
갈 수 있다라고 했는데 오늘 1천을
돌파하고 있어요.
>> 어, 그리고 어, 서스퀘 하나라는 그
외국계 증권사에서도 엄청
올려줬거든요. 그러면서 마이크론의
목표 주가 600달러에서 1750달러
>> 아, 1700까지 나오고 있는 사.
>> 네. 샌디스크 같은 경우는
2,000달러. 목표 주가가
2,000달러였는데 3,250달러를
줬고요. 이유는 너무 간단합니다.
디램과 랜드의 평균 판매 단가가
전분기 대비 최소 50% 이상 올라갈
것이고 이게 지속적인 강세 마진
구조가 계속해서 좋아질 것이다.
그래서 우리 서스퀘 하나는 매모리 자
반도체 제조사들에 대한 실적 전망치를
상향할 수밖에 없다라고 했습니다.
마이크론 같은 경우는 일단 금요일
마감는 970달러였고요. 샌디스크
같은 경우는 1,694달러였네요.
>> 네. 그러니까 지금 이런 흐름 속에
있다라는 거를 자꾸 저희가 강조드리는
거예요. 그러니까 그런 거 묻지
마세요. 예를 들어서
>> 지금 들어가요.
>> 다 오른 거 아닌가요? 살까요,
말까요? 그런 질문할 때가 아니라는
말씀을이 도도한
>> 이
>> 옛말로 뭐예요? 장강의 흐름처럼
이렇게 도도 흘러가는이 흐름을 지금
보셔야 된다는 뜻입니다.
>> 그리고 또 하나 뭐냐면 야 반도체
얘기 좀 그만해라. 만할 수가
없어요, 지금. 그 아니하셨.
>> 아, 여러분 투자에서는 투자에서는
새로운 걸 찾는게 아니에요.
>> 이렇게 유튜브 돌아다니 보시면어
이렇게 보시면 요즘 이제 새로운 얘기
하려고 막 조금씩 얘기하잖아요. 많이
얘기해. 그런 얘기. 그런 얘기
들으실 필요가 없어요. 새로운 걸
쫓아다니는게 아니에요. 어. 그래서
여러분들이 너무 멀리 가지 마시라 그
말씀을 드리고. 자, 그래서 삼성과
우리 코스피의 지금 몸집이
달라졌어요. 네, 맞습니다.
>> 네. 그 지금 해 주시죠.
>> 어, 삼성전자
달러 기준의 어, 시가 총액이요.
현재 한번 리프레시 해 볼까요? 1조
5,억 달러고요. 그 바로 위가
메타입니다. 메타 1조 6,억
달러예요.요 정도는 우리가 또 해 볼
수 있잖아요.
>> 어, SK 하이닉스 같은 경우도 1조
1천억 달러 현재 넘어가고 있고요.
그래서 한화 기준으로 삼성전자는
>> 드디어
>> 2,조대
>> 2,조 시대를 열었습니다.
>> 삼성전자 2,조 시대.
>> 하이닉스 1700조 시대를 지금
>> 열었습니다. 오늘.
>> 네. 삼 어 삼성전자 현재도 9%
이상의 강세 계속해서 이어가고
있고요. 장 중에 34만9,000원
터치했습니다. 네. 우리가 만든 우리
기업이지만 이제 내 새끼가 아니에요.
>> 전 지구를 호령하는 레벨로 올라갔다는
거를 인정하셔야 되고요.
>> 맞습니다.
>> 그래서 이제 덩달아 예 코스피는 지금
또
>> 예
>> 8,863포인트
지나가
>> 그래서 세개 시총
>> 5유에 등극했습니다.
>> 아
>> 우리가 뭐 제가 코스피 만 간다라고
책 쓸 때 자료 수집할 때가 13위
막 이랬거든요. 그 제가 무조건
10위 안쪽으로 가야지. 8위까진
가야지. 네가
방송하 올라가서
>> 지금 5위까지 5위까지 올라갔습니다.
>> 그래서 이제 우리 위에는 누가 있냐면
>> 제일 위에는 이제 미국 있고 중국
있고 일본 있고 밑에 인도가 있고
우리가 우리 그다음에 우리예요.
인도가 달러로 4조 9,200억 불
정도 되고 우리가 4조
5,400억불이에요. 조금만 더 가면
인도 정도는 제길 수도 있겠
인도부터 제끼는 거 말씀을 드리면
일단 MSCI 지수에서 인도의 비중이
많이 내려갔어요, 요즘에. 그래서
외국인의 유출이 많아서 아마 인도는
진짜 가능하지 않을까 싶은데요.
>> 제가 인도 기업들 탐방을 많이
다녔었거든요. 어, 애널리스트 할
때.
>> 근데 인도가 주가가 한참 오를 때는
사실 이익은 안 나고 수급으로 오를
때였죠. 네. 음.
>> 그래서 이제 그런 임머진 국가,
그러니까 개발도상국에 대한 기대가
인구도 많으니까 그냥 기대가
컸잖아요. 우리하고는 차원이 다르다.
우리는 뭘로 움직인다? 우린 뭐
이익을 내고
>> 있잖아요. 네. 거기다가 하나만 더
덧붙여 드리면 골드만 삭스에서
어 모두가 그리드하다 노피어다라면서
모두가 지금 막 시장에 불을 켜고
보고 있다라는 이야기를 하는데 거기서
끄트머리 어떤 이야기를 하냐면
>> 미국과 이란의 실질적인 휴전 타결이
성사되면
시장의 무게 중심은 AI 승자 독식
구조로 가긴 갈 텐데 그다음으로
관심을 가져야 하는 건 신흥국이다.
비미국계다라는 이야기를 합니다. 원유
수급이 잘 되면 이런 나라들 더
좋아질 거다라는 이야기.
>> 그 당연 우리나라입니다. 예. 자,
그래서 이런 다시 한번 제가 제차
제3, 제4 말씀드립니다만 이거는
이미 큰 물결이에요. 더 이상
의심하지 마시고이 물결 위에
올라타시길 바라고요. 예. 지금 우리
댓글에서도 내 코스닥은 어떻해요? 어
코스 기 좀해주세요. 살려주세요.
이런 뭐 정말 간절한 이런 댓글들도
많은데 뭐 개별적으로 드릴 말씀은
많습니다만
>> 아
예를 들어서 이쪽으로 빨리 옮겨
타는게 전략적으로 빨리빨리 수정하는게
중요하다는 말씀을 좀
>> 빨리 캐치하시길 바라겠습니다.
>> 네. 손실을 줄이는게 중요하다고 두
분이 항상 말씀하셨잖아요.
그거 기억해 보시면 좋겠네요. 네.
코스닥도 저희가 앞으로 얘기를 계속
해 보고요. 어쨌든
>> 어 코스닥은 지난번에도 말씀드렸듯이
>> 정책이 중요하기 때문에에
>> 지방 선거 이후로 어 정부의
정책이라든가 어 주식 시장 활성화
그런 기대를 좀 해보도록 하겠습니다.
>> 그럼 이제 한 말씀만 더 드릴게요.
이게 너무나 중요한 주제기 때문에
그러면 야 우리가 시총 5위고 삼성
이렇게 잘 나가고 하이 잘 나가면은
>> 계속 내네 잘 나간다고 얘기하는
거야라고 할 때 아까 이제 이익이 잘
나기도 하고요. 또 하나는 지금도
싸다. 우리가 이런 얘기를 많이
드려요. 그 이유는 뭐냐면 그냥
>> 우리 증시도
>> 이게 가볍게 대만하고 비교해 보면 답
딱 나와요.
>> 님 설명 좀 해 주셔요.
>> 네. 대만 증시랑 비교했을 때 아직도
우리나라는 저평가이다라고
합니다. 지금 PER 기준 선행
PER입니다. 선행 PER 기준으로
코스피가 8.1배라고 되어 있는데요.
저거 지금 어닝 그니까 실적에 대한
리비전이 더 올라가게 되면서 어느
측정에서는 7.7 700까지 합니다.
어 그 정도로 굉장히 저평가되어 있고
대만이 지금 20배가 살짝 안
되잖아요.
>> 두 배 차입니다.
>> 두 배 차이 납니다.
>> 저 PR 좀 설명해 주세요.
>> 그러니까 너 올해 장사해서 이익
얼마나 남길 거야라고 하면 얼마나
남길 건데요라고 하면 어 네가 그
정도 이익을 남기는 애니까 나는
그거에 대해서 몇 배 정도 너 값을
더 쳐 줄게. 요렇게 보시면 되는데
우리는 지금 이익난 거에 비해서 예를
들면 일곱 배 정도 더 쳐 줄게.
아, 감사합니다. 이랬는데 알고
봤더니 옆집가 가지고 대만에 가서는
너는 이익난 거보다 내가 19배 쳐
줄게. 네값을. 이러고 얘기했다는
거예요. 그러니까 그걸 알고 나면
우리 어떻게 돼요? 왜 나 이렇게
싸게 잡아 줘요? 응. 옆집이하고
비슷하게 잡아 줘요.
>> 이럴 여지가 있다는 거예요. 그래서
대만 수준에 근접하거나 지금보다도
훨씬 우리 뭐값 조금만 더 불려가고
>> 어, 재값을 받기만 한다면 올라갈
일이 올라갈 길이 더 많다. 룸이 더
많다. 아직 우리는 싸게 평가받고
있다. 이런 뜻인데요.
>> 음. 그
PER로만 보면은 당연히 우리가 지금
어 싸 그럼 이제 문제는 뭐냐면 왜
그럼 우리는 대만만큼 평가를 못
받느냐라고 했을 때 그동안 저평가
받았던 여러 요인들이 몇 개
있거든요. 이제 그런 것들만 조금씩
우리가 이제 시장을 좀 이쁘게
만들면서 계약해 간다면 지금 벌고
있는이 돈네
>> 우리의 실력 이걸 이제 평가받으면
앞으로도 더 올라갈 일이 많다.
그러니까 고점론 얘기는 넣어 더 넣어
더
>> 네.음 음. 저 PR은 조금 더 이제
간결하게 접근을 해 보면 이런
얘기거든요. 제가 지금 한국의 주식
시장에 투자를 하면
>> 그 원금을 회수하는데 8년 걸린다는
얘기예요.
>> 그런데 대만에 투자하면 19년
걸린다는 얘기예요.
>> 어 그만큼 어 예를 들면 뭐라고
얘기할까요? 한국은 금방 회수할 수
있다.
>> 네. 저평가 받고 있다.
>> 그죠? 그러니까 저게 제대로 평가만
받아도 우리가 대만 대만 여행가
보셨어요?
>> 안 가봤어요.
>> 자랑하는 거예요? 또
>> 안가 안 가봤어.
>> 아니 저 못 가봤어. 요즘 많이들
가시더라고.
>> 근데 저는 주식 시장은 저렇게 두 배
이상 좋은 건가? 대만이
>> 그니까 대만에 대해서 저렇게 비싸게
평가하는 경우 결국 TSMC 때문이고
TSMC는 실적에 들쭉날쭉함이
없다라고 우리가 기대하기
때문이잖아요.
근데 우리도 이제 그렇게 되고
있잖아요.
>> 네. 장기 계약을 통해서 어 내려가는
그 실적의 폭이 적어질 것이다라는
기대감은 큽니다.
>> 음. 근데 한 가지 가장 다른 점은
또 있어 있긴 해요. 제가 지난번에도
잠깐 말씀드렸는데 예를 들어서
TSMC의 협력 업체들은 영업
이익률이 평균적으로 20%
이상입니다.
>> 네. 그런데 삼성전자나 SK대의 협력
업체들 우리나라들은 그렇게 안 돼요.
물론 일부 업체는 높은 회사들도
있겠지만 그러니까 주식 시장이 진짜
더 오르고 저평가가 해소되기 위해서는
함께 가는 거예요. 그래서 우리나라
반도체 회사들이 함께 가는 전략을
써야 됩니다.
>> 그러기 위해서 정부의 정책도 거기에
올해 하반기나 앞으로는 맞춰
줘야겠죠. 그래서 혼자 돈을 보는게
영업 이익이 80%가 웬 말입니까?이
이 얘기는 반대로 얘기하면 돈을 안
쓴다는 얘기예요. 그래서 여기
10%만 쓰자. 협력 업체한테 그러면
삼성전자 70% 영업이 이렇게
유지하고 그 10%는 협력 업체들
가면 여기서 코스닥에 상장되 있는
협력 업체들이 주가가 쫙 오를
>> 거니요네.
>> 이런 선순화 이런 선수화를
만들어야지네.
>> 요즘 하이닉스에서도 그래도 가격을 좀
맞춰 주는 분위기가 됐다라고
하더라고요. 협력 업체들에게. 그래서
협력 업체들이 판매하는 단가도 조금씩
올라가고 있대요.
>> 그래야죠. 당연하게 혼자 돈 벌면
됩니까? 같이 해야지.
>> 그렇죠. 네.
>> 그다음에 이제 수급 관해 오늘 지금
코스피 코스피 사상 최고치 삼성전자
어 10% 상승이 우리 이런 얘기를
하고 있는데 조금 걱정되는 걱정은 안
되지만 이제 한번 생각해 봐야 될
부분은 늘 말씀드립니다만 이제 외국인
매도 부분이 이제 수급에서 늘
걸리는데요. 이렇게 오르면
>> 덜어요. 걔네들은 또 어쩔 수
없습니다. 예. 그러니까 이제
조만간에 또다시 이제 매도가 나올
수밖에 없어요. 걔네들이 잡아 놓은
아 비중이라든지 이런 거를 지금 계속
상향 우리 하고 있기 때문에 올라서
돌어내고 올라서 돌려내는 그런 현상이
또 생깁니다.
>> 그게 약간 이제 이제 걸리는데 그런
문제는 뭐냐면 받으면 돼요. 근데
이제 누가 받을 거냐? 연기금이 받을
거냐? 개인이 받을 거냐, 또 일반
기관들이 받을 거냐이 문제인데요
부분만 이제 우리가 얼마나 받아낼
것이냐 또 리밸런싱 끝나고 난 다음에
>> 밑을 좀 다지면서 다시 이제 올라갈
수 있 있는 그 수급 관련한
>> 요런 부분만 이제 조금 이제
>> 주의를 하시면서 보시면 될 거
같아요.
>> 오늘 같은 경우는 현재 외국인이 거의
2조원 가까이 팔고 있는데 금융
투자에서 2조원 받고요. 연기금에서
5,700억 원 가량의 매수세가
일단은 현재는 나타나고 있습니다.
연금이 좀 사는 거 같아요.
>> 네. 정거래일이랑 오늘 삽니다.
그러니까 지난번에 저희가 말씀드린
것처럼 연금이 이제 국내 주식 비중
관련한 얘기를 일단은 어 혹시 파는
거 아니야?이 이 부분에 관해서
걱정을 싹 일단 해소했는데 추가적으로
얼마나 더 살지 요게 이제 조금
관심이고요. 만약에 이제 추가적으로
더 많이 안 사거나
>> 약간 정중동을 유지하면은 이제 수급
부담이 단기간에서는 이제 개인적으로
옮겨올 가능성이 조금 있는데 이때
이제 개인들이 다 받을 수 있느냐
>> 요게 이제 조금 이제 관 단기간의
관전 포인트입니다. 실적이나
펀더멘탈은 전혀 문제가 없고요. 수급
관련하는 조금 이제 신경 써 보시면
될 거 같아요.
>> 예. 좋습니다. 저희가 수출 관련된
얘기를 좀 깊게 해봤는데요.
이게 5월 수출입 동향이라고 이렇게
자료가 나오거든요.
>> 이게 산업통상부 자료인데 여러분도
한번 보세요. 이게 너무 재밌어요.
그러니까 대한민국은 수출로 사는
나라잖아요. 그렇기 때문에 우리가
함께 이런 자료들을 어 투자자라고
하신다면 관심이 있으시면 여러분들이
한번 산업통상부의 보도 자료를 수출인
월간 통계 자료거든요. 이걸 한번
보실 필요가 있습니다. 근데 흥미로운
지점이 뭔지
>> 아세요? 이거 굉장히 중요한 자료인데
다운로드 수가요? 1천회 정도밖에 안
돼요.
>> 아, 그래요? 아, 그랬나?
>> 지금 볼까요? 어,
>> 지금 별로 안 본다는 거예요. 어.
>> 오.
>> 지금 여러분 드라마보다 더 중요해요.
>> 그렇죠.
>> 그거 뭐예요? 요즘 유행하는 드라마
나무 뭐예요?
>> 뭐예요?
>> 무나 무슨
>> 나무세 뭐 그
>> 무가치함과 싸우고 있다. 뭐가
>> 그러면 가치와 싸우고 싶어? 어
>> 이건 같치잖아요.
>> 5월 수출입 동양 지금 산업통상자원부
보도 참고자료에 올라와 있는데 조회수
812회입니다.
>> 거 보세요. 이게 엄청 중요한
자료인데 1천명도 안 본다고요.
나오면 여러분 아닙니다.
>> 아니 물론 이제 기자들이 다 기사를
써 주긴 한데 그래도 원문을 봐야
>> 기사를 잘 못 쓴다고요.
>> 그러니까 우리 직접 봐야 돼. 예.
그래서 여기 보시면
>> 대한민국이 지금 어떤 수출이 증가하고
있고 아 재밌다. 여기서 제가 오늘
딱 눈에 띈게 화장품 수출이
증가해요. 맞아요. 그런 얘기들이
이제 기사는 지면의 양이 정해져
있으니까 속속들이 못 쓰는 것도
많아요.
>> 여러분 지금 무가치한 거 싸울 때가
아니에요. 가치와 싸울 때 가치 뭘
무가치하고 싸워요 무가치.
아, 화장품 수출 코멘트만 간단하게
숫자만 드리면 5월 수출액 11억
8,억 달러로 전년 동기 대비 24%
늘었고요. 역대 5월 수출 중에서
올해가 가장 높은 수출액이고
하고 어 다른 나라들은 뭐 고만고만
그 전과 비슷하게 수출을 했는데 중동
쪽에서의 큰 폭에 증가가 있었다라고
합니다. 그러니까 화장품 수출의 또
포인트가 그거거든요. 다변화.
>> 음. 미국, 유럽, 중동, 그리고
남미까지 어떻게 파이프라인을 더
가져가느냐의 포인트인데 전쟁이
있었음에도 불구하고 중동에서
있었다라는 것을 좀 긍정적으로 볼 수
있을 것 같습니다.
>> 여러분께 이제 꿀팁을 하나 드리면
아, 주가를 좀 누가 확 시원하게 좀
예측해 주면 안 돼요? 우리 종목
오르는지 안 오르는지 좀 알려 주시면
안 돼요. 이런 얘기 많이 하는데요.
>> 네.
그 주가하고 거의 100% 싱크가
맞는 자료가 수출 자료예요.
>> 이거는 여러분 의심하지 마세요.
주가가 궁금하면 그 회사, 그 업종,
그 섹터의 수출 자료를 보시면 이거는
딱 들어맞아요. 그러니까 이게 사실은
족보예요. 시험으로 치면은이 자료가
족보거든요.
>> 너무 중요해요.
>> 놀랍지 않습니까? 1천명이 안 봐요.
>> 예. 그리고이 자료를 이제 많이
보시던 분들은 이제 여기서 방금 말씀
이강훈 대표님처럼 이렇게 딱 유의미한
포인트를 캐치해 낼 수가 있어. 계속
봐야 보이거든요. 근데 예전에는이
수출 통계 관련해서
>> 아
수출 우리가 이제 잡고 있는
우리나라의 수출 시장 이거를 딱 몇대
시장이다 이렇게 해서 하나 둘 셋 넷
다섯 여섯 일곱 여덟 아홉 아홉 개
시장으로 딱 이렇게 구별을 해
놨어요. 그리고 주요 품목도 몇 개
이렇게 해 놨었습니다. 근데 지금
이게 자료가 바뀌었어요. 그래서
품목을 20개로 늘렸습니다.
>> 그러니까 더 자세히 보게 해 놨어요.
지금 여기 한두 달 사이 바뀐 거
같아. 네대품에
여러분이 관심 있는 섹터가 더 자세히
나와요. 그래서이 중에 어 내가 뭐
하고 있는데 수치 좀 주나 넣나
이렇게 자세히 볼 수가 있거든요.
요런 걸 계속 자료에에
>> 이걸 킵해 놓고 채깔아 놓고 나올
때마다 이렇게 직접 보시는게
중요해요.네
>> 맞습니다. 그런데이 화장품을 저희가
좀 생각할 필요가 있어요. 아까도
권다영커님 말씀드린 하신 것처럼
미국의 수출이 증가하고 있고
>> 이게 일종의 트렌드가 돼 가는 거
같아요. 이미 그렇게 돼가고 있고.
>> 어, 그리고 한국 화장품은 사실은
수출에서는 기초 제품 위주로 보시면
되고요. 그것도 나눠서 나오거든요.
기초 제품 위주로 보시면 되고
마스크팩 보시면 되고 미국에서의
수출이 얼마나 느는지 그리고 거기다가
미국과 유럽은 그 큰 아마존 이런
데서 행사하면은 그전에 막 당깁니다.
그들이
>> 어, 미리. 그래서 그런 지표도 잘
보시면 좋을 것 같아요.
>> 박시 대표님,
>> 지금 미국의 MG들, 젊은 세대들이
>> 한국의이 화장품을 쓰면서 새로 생긴
단어가 있어요.
>> 아세요, 그거?
>> 뭔? 몰라요.
>> 뭐예요?
>> 아, 아실 거예요. 글래스킨.
>> 아,
>> 글래스킨. 이거 그니까 피부가 우리
너무 좋잖아요. 얘로 연예인들이나
>> 한국 여자들은 화 피부 좋다고.
>> 예. 그러니까 그 글래스 스킨 이거
쓰면 만든다 하면서 한국 화장품이
일종에
>> 트렌드화 되고 있대요. 근데 글래스
스킨의 반대말은 뭔지 아십니까?
>> 뭐요?
>> 아스팔트 스킨.
>> 아
>> 진짜요? 농담이에요. 아재기가
금지예요.
>> 농담입니다.
>> 농담이 경고 두번 태장 태장
>> 태장이에요.
>> 다음
>> 주위 주의
>> 다음 방송에서 옐로 카드 만들어 갖고
올게요. 네. 알겠습니다. 저희 첫
번째 뉴스를 굉장히 기했는데 두
번째로 가보겠습니다.
>> 네. 두 번째는 지금 젠슨 이야기를
좀 해야겠는데요. 젠슨은 현재 GTC
2026 타이페이 키노트 연설을 진행
중입니다. 우리 방송과 같이 시작을
해서 현재 30분째에 이야기를 하고
있고 제가 계속 화면을 보는게 젠슨왕
골려고 보고 있거든요. 지금까지
이야기한 거를 쭉 보니까 아 제일
중요한 건 그건 거 같아요. 지금까지
얘기한 건 우리는 풀스택 회사가 될
거야. 다 할 거야. 아, 그래서
GPU, CPU 링크 지금은 또 AI
팩토리 이야기를 하고 있습니다.
그래서 다 한다라고 하고 있는 와중에
이거 끝내고 어디 온다? 한국에
온다. 그래서 한국에서 누구
만나냐라는
이야기들 지금 때문에 관련된 종목들
급등하고 있습니다. LG 그룹주
오늘도 급등하네요. 어, LG 전자
상한가 들어갔고요. 오늘은 또 LG
헬로비전이 상한가를 들어갔어요.
>> 헬로비전은 뭐 하는 회사예요? 그리
왜 붙었는지 모르겠 아 죄송합니다.
예 아무튼 합니다.
>> 아니 아니 좋은 회사입니다.
>> 아 좋은 회사인데네 뭐 여튼 LG
CNS 현재 28% 29% 급등 LG
24%대 급등 LG 이노택 17%대
급등 LG U플러스 6 6%대 상승
그리고 LG가 지분을 갖고 있는
로보스타 상한가 또 들어가는 흐름들
보여 주고 있습니다. 근데 어 오늘
저녁에도요 행사 마치고 그 대만의 한
선술집에서
최태원 회장이랑 뭐 누가 갈지는
정확하게는 모르겠어요. 근데 뭐 삼성
SK 현대차 네이버 요렇게 해서
저녁을 먹는다라는 이야기가 저는
있습니다. 그래서 아 한 선술집을
예약을 했대요. 그래서 이미 지금
>> 출장 가신 애널리스트 분들께서 거기
어딘지 막 사진 찍어서 올려
주시더라고요.
>> 아 진짜
>> 좀 짜치는 거 아닙니까?
아니 뭐 좋지만 훌륭하지만 너무
술집까지 쫓아다니 거 너무 심한 거
아니에요?
>> 아니 우리가 그 깜부 치킨 때 전
세계가 너무 감동한 거죠. 와
젠슨왕이 가서 말이야
>> 이렇게 돼 가지고
>> 지금 어디까지 가야 됩니까 이거? 아
어쨌든 뭐 좋은 일이죠. 네.
대한민국 기업들이 전 세계 최고인
최대 기업인 M비DI 젠슨왕하고
친해진다는 건 좋은 거고요.
>> 근데 전 어쨌든 젠순왕이 한국도 자주
오고 이런 뭐 CEO들하고 자주
만난다는 건 그만큼 대한민국 기업들이
중요하다는 얘기예요. 겁니다.이 바쁜
사람이 음
>> 왜 만나요? 그거 자체가 의미가
있다는 거예요. 우리가 필요한
거고요. 우리랑 할 얘기가 많다는
겁니다.네
>> 맞아. 네. 그래서 지금 와서는 여러
가지 일정들이 지금 뭐 정확하게는
아닌데 소위 말하는 이제 이게 썰로
돌고 있습니다. 그래서 6월 5일에
방안을 해서 그날 이해진이 네이버에
이해진 거의 회동이 정이 되어 있게
나와요.
>> 저런 지금 보도들이 막 나오고
있어요. 예. 지금 LG
구강모회장하고
정의선회장도 만나고 두산 그룹과도의
만남이 예정이 되어 있다라고 하고요.
여러분 6월 7일 일요일에 지금
두산베어스 시구를 한다라는 보도들이
전해지고 있습니다.
>> 두산배어스 1등 갑니까?
>> 지금 몇이야? 지금 올려주세요. 두산
몇입니까?
>> 두산 몇인지 모르겠는데 여튼 그래서
어 이날 그 경기가 두산이랑 NC인가
뭐 그렇대요. 네. 뭐고요. 그러고
나서 월요일이 되면 네이버의 판교
사업을 방문할 예정이다라는 이야기까지
함께 전해지고 있습니다. 그래서 금토
1월 정도 4일이나이 바쁜 사람이
4일이나 한국에 있는다 뭐 이렇게
>> 네. 아니 제젠순왕 비서는 돈 많이
벌겠어.
>> 그러겠죠.
>> 만나면 다 스케줄 아니까 그 전에
주식 딱 사 놓으면 되잖아. 그죠?
>> 와, 누군지 진짜 궁금.
>> 네.
>> 첩자를 보내겠습니다.
>> 첩자를 보내겠네.
>> 거기다가 가족들이 다 같이 지금
야구장에 간대요. 딸이랑 뭐 아들도
지금 같이 다니고 있어 가지고는 그
가족들이 다 같이 지금 야구장에서
만날 수 있지 않을까라고 하면서 한
섹션을 다 엔비디아가 지금
예약했다라는 이야기 전해집니다.
>> 아, 이거 흥미로운데. 두산 베어스가
6위고요. LG트스가 1입니다.
삼성은 3위. 아. 아, 이거 막상
막데. 지금 두산 로보틱스
상한가거든요. 어떻게 될지 궁금하네.
>> 자, 젠수당이 와서 진짜 두산 배워스
1등으로 올라가면 제가
인정하겠습니다.
>> 그까 지금 저희가 뭐 뭐 유명인 동선
따라잡게 하는 가십을 하려고 하는게
아니고요. 이게 지금 중요한 테마고
하나의 흐름이기 때문에 말씀드리는
거예요. 그래서 지금 다음 준비된
자료 또 해 주시죠.
>> 네. 다음 준비된 자료. 하나증권에서
젠슨 화항 왔을 때 뭐 봐야 돼?
음를정해주셨더라고요.
그래서 1차부동 때 무슨 일이 있었나
정리를 해봤더니 그때는 사실이펙
와가지고는 우리 정부하고도 만나고 어
그룹 회장들과도 다 만나고 그때
GPU 26만 개를 받겠다라고 약속을
받게 된 그때였습니다. 그때 그룹주들
지금 보이시겠지만 엄청 올랐어요.
이때
>> 네. 그래서 이번에도 좀 기대를 크게
하는 거 같고요. 이때는 사실
GPU를 받고 메모리를 준다에 조금
더 가까웠다면 이번에는 피지컬 AI
쪽으로 관심을 많이 가지고 있는 거
같습니다. 그래서 LG 두산도 그
때문에 움직이고 있고 어 HBM
관련해서 아직도 사실은 좀 노이즈가
많아요. 왜냐면 베라루빈이라는 최첨단
칩의 HBN4가 처음으로 얹어지는데
아직 추화가 안 됐기 때문에 되니 안
되니 아직도 말이 많거든요. 부분에
대해서도 어떻게 이야기를 하는지
거기다가 이해진 의장하고도 처음
만나고 국광모 회장하고도 처음 만나기
때문에 뭘 어떻게 할지에 대한
기대감을 가져가고 있습니다. 그래서이
리포트에서 사진 볼게 아니라 청구서와
비례를 보자.
>> 뭘 받아올지라는 코멘트 있습니다.
>> 제목이 아주 재밌게 뽑혔어요.
>> 댄스왕이랑 만나서 뭐 깜부를
먹었느냐라는 그 사진이 중요한게
아니고
>> 뭐죠? 아까
>> 주문서를 보라. 치 사진이 아닌
주문서를
>> 사진이 아니라 주문서의
>> 문서 뭐야? 당 몇 마리 이런 거?
>> 당면
>> 아 이번에는 아마 지금 전망으로는
한국에 와서 삼겹살에 소주 먹지
않을까라는네
>> 그러면 삼겹살 주식뭐
>> 근데 이제 중요한 건 네
>> 젠슨왕의 고민을 우리가 읽을 필요가
있다는 거예요. 그러니까 엔비디아도
GPU만 팔아서는 앞으로 성장이 없을
거 아닙니다.
>> 그렇죠. 지금도 그래서 지금 그
얘기를 하는 거죠.
>> 그죠? 그러니까 전 세계 모든
기업들은 성장하는게 목표잖아요.
그러면 어 GPU를 팔아서 지금 높게
이익을 나는 것도 중요하지만이 돈으로
그러면 다음번 뭘 할 거냐? 그래서
그 핵심은 피지컬 AI인데 그 중심에
로봇이 들어가는 거고 로봇 생태계를
만들었을 때 AI는 과연 어디까지
누구와 함께 진출할 건가가 되게
중요해 보입니다.
>> 맞습니다. 그리고 이제 젠슨왕과 LG
그룹이 만난다는 얘기 나오기 전에
사실은 살짝 시장이 먼저 기대를
이것과 상관없이 하고 있었거든요.
그래서 어 LG가 어 좋을 거 같은데
이런 기대를 하고 있는 상황에서 이제
젠수랑 회동 얘기가 얹어지니까 지금
LG 그룹주들이 연일 지금 연속
상한가를 지금 다 보이고 있어요.
그래서 지금 용어가 그냥 아예
>> LG 그룹주 이렇게 안 하고 그냥 팀
LG 이렇게 부르는 용어도 나왔어요.
예.
>> 네. 아, 근데 야구도 1등하니까 어
>> 야구도 만약에 올해 1등하면은
작년에이어서 이연속 우승인데
>> 대단합니다.
>> 응원을 LG로 바꿔야 되나 지금
아닙니다.
>> 원래 하나
>> 팀을 막 바꿔요.
>> 하나편 아닙니까? 하나편.
안 바꿔. 안 받고 요즘 잘하고
있어요.
근데 제 딸아이가 LG팬이야.
>> 아
>> 걔는 1등만 좋아하더라고.
>> 그래서 어쨌거나 지금 때문에 올라간
테마가 적어도 어 방한 일정이
마무리되는
>> 네.
>> 이번 주까지는 계속 이어질 수 있다.
그래서 여기도 관심을 가져 보시고
사진 플러스 어떤 청구서, 어떤
계약서, 어떤 주문서가 뒤어나올 수
있을지 예. 꼭 보셔야 된다.
>> 네. 네. 지금 젠슨의 영상을 제가
보고 있는데요. 꽤 길게 앞에는
AI의
전 밸류체인을 내가 할 거야라는
이야기를 했고요. 지금은 어 AI
팩토리 그리고 피지컬 AI에 대한
이야기를 하고 있는 중입니다.
>> 네.
>> 피지컬 AI의 핵심은 다시
말씀드리지만 사실 노봇이 있고요.
그래서 세 번 세 번째 뉴스도 의미가
좀 있어 보이고. 네. 세 번째 뉴스
삼성전자의 강한 상승의 원인이라고 어
체크해 볼 수 있겠고요. 현재
삼성전자 9.9%대 9%대 강세에
보이면서 34만8,000원 선
지나가고 있습니다. 어 삼성전자가
휴먼노이드를 포함한 로봇 사업에 대한
경영진단에 착수했다라는 소식을 소식이
전해졌습니다. 사업 부진의 원인을
찾기보다는
사내의 로봇 사업의 현황을 점검하고
중장기 전략을 재정비하기 위한
차원이다라고 하는데 삼성전자도이 로봇
사업이 부분부분으로 조금 떨어져
있다라고 알려져 있어요. 그래서
요거를 하나로 좀 해 가지고
휴먼노이드 쪽으로 밀려는 것
아니냐라는 그런 기대감 때문에
삼성전자가 현재 이런 급등을 보여주고
있습니다.
>> 네. 삼성전자도 할 수 있죠. 저는
대한민국 기업들 대단하다. 우리가
함께 가야 된다. 근데 삼성자는 제가
이거는 그냥 예측입니다.
>> 예상하는 거고요.
>> 삼성자는 어 M&를 통해서 어 로버에
진출하는게 더 유리하겠죠. 그런
의미에서 제가 지금 표 하나 어를
보여 드리면 좋을 거 같은데음.
>> 지금 레인보우 로보틱스가 14%대
급등하면서 80만 원 다시 돌파에
성공하는 모습들 보여주고 있습니다.
왜 레인보우 로보틱스가 오르냐?
삼성전자가 최대 주주입니다.
>> 근데 거기다가 코옵션까지 지금 갖고
있어서요 콜옵션을 행사를 하면 과반
이상의 지분을 삼성전자가 갖고 갈 수
있어서 시장에서는 레인보우 로보틱스가
아니라 삼성 로보틱스 됐으면
좋겠다라는
투자자들의 기대를 가져가고 있습니다.
지금 상한가 가고 있는 두산
로보틱스도 두산 그룹이 최대
주주고요. 오늘 LG 그룹주들이
좋잖아요. 그래서 LG가 지분을 갖고
있는 회사들 로보티즈, 엔젤로틱스,
로보스타 같은 종목들 급등하고 있고
SK에서는 유일 로보틱스의 지분을 좀
갖고 있는데 오늘 유일 로보틱스도
함께 급등합니다.
>> 네. 그러니까 보시면 삼성이
상대적으로 어 레인보우 로보틱스
말고는 투자한 데가 없잖아요. 그래서
추가적으로 M& 한다거나 그런 진출이
필요하겠죠. 그
>> 그런데 저희가 저 로봇 기업들 좀
유의하실 필요는 있어요. 뭐냐면
실적이 그만큼 받쳐주느냐 거기에 좀
의문이 있지 않습니까?
>> 맞습니다. 아까도 우리가 P 살짝
말씀드렸는데 그 레인보우 로보틱스가
오늘도 올라가고 있습니다만
>> P 기준으로라면은 세계 1등이에요.
>> 네.
>> 그러니까 아까 저희가 너 만 원 벌면
내 내가 너 몸값 여덟 배 쳐 줄게.
이렇게 얘기했잖아요. 또는 이제 같은
비유지만 너 만 원 벌 내가 너한테
투자하면 8년이면 원금 회수돼 이런
개념이거든요. 근데 레인보우
로보틱스는
7천이 넘나요?
>> 8천이 넘나 그래요. 그러니까 만 원
버는데 8,000배 쳐 줄게 이렇게
돼 있어.
>> 그러면 뭐 8,년 기다려요.
>> 8년 기다려야 되는 거 상황인
거예요. 그러니까 뭐야? 왜 이렇게
비싸?
적은데 왜 이렇게 문값을 많이 계속
불려 쳐준 거야라고 하니까이
>> 일단은 테마 로봇 테마에 타 있고
삼성이 투자한 회사다라는 것 때문에
터 있지만
>> 네
>> 실적으로 보면은 너무 비싼 그 괴리가
있기는 있죠. 네.
>> 어 지금 저 너무 깜짝 놀랬는데
>> 왜요?
>> 피리너
>> 어떻게 됐어요? 더 올라갔어요.
>> 만죠.
>> 만이야. 이거는 말이 안 세 개 만년
기다려야 돼.
인류 역사와 함께합니다.
>> 아 근데 뭐 그런 회사니까 기본적으로
시작하는 로봇들은 뭐 50배씩 뭐
이렇게 가는 거 뭐 100배도 갈 수
있
>> 근데 말씀드린 것처럼 유의하실 필요는
있다.
>> 네. 아니, 그러니까 그거잖아요.
지금 레인보우 로보틱스가 투자만 계속
하고 있고 근데 이게 투자금이
들어오고 뭐가 되면 그리고 삼성의
뭔가 공장에 바로 들어가게 되면
실적이 바로 찍힐 거니까 그
기대감으로 지금 오른다라고 정리해
드릴 수 있겠네요.
>> 네. 근데 이제 여러분들께서 이제 잘
보셔야 되는게 사실은 갑자기 로보트
하나 띵는게 아니거든요. 예를 들어
지금이 로봇 관련한 피지컬 AI
관련한에
무언가를 한다라고 하면은 그룹이
사실은 이제 전략적으로 부문 부분이
다 붙어야 되거든요.
>> 그게 어쩌면 우리나라만큼 잘할 수
있는 이런 토대가 많지가 않아요.
그래서
>> 현대 그룹과 지금 LG 그룹이
동반에서 지금이 피지컬 관련해서
테마를 잡고 있는게 뭐냐면 예를 들어
현대도 머리는 누가 하자. 네동했
그러면 관절은 누가 할래? 그다음에
AI 관련한 공이라든지이
정확한 시스템은 누가 만들래 이렇게
해가지고 쭉 보면 그룹이 영향을
가지고 이렇게 이렇게 계획을 가지고
있고요. LG도 저번에 권영님이
우리가 꼼꼼형이 정의를 한번 하지
않습니까? LG 그룹 내에서 로봇
관련한이 수직 계열화가 얼추 가능해
보여요. 예. 그런데 이제 삼성이
이제 그걸 한다라고 하면 삼성도
가능하거든요. 지금 뭐 반도체는 누가
뭐는 뭐 뭐는 뭐 그래 그러분 다 할
수 있는데 요기 요기만 좀 비어
있네. 그럼 그거 사
>> 음
>> 사서 끼겨. 그럼 우리도 계열 안으로
다 들어올 수 있어. 네크준
이것아셔야 됩니다.
>> 근데 로봇도 반도체를 엄청 쓸 거
같은데
>> 반도체를 많이 쓰기는 하는데
아직까지는 왜 이런 기업들이 주목을
받냐면
>> 어 원가에서 차지하는 비중에
하드웨어가 훨씬 더 높습니다.
아직까지는. 예.
액터 비싸고 손하도
들어가야 돼요. 그러다 보니까
아직까지 원가로 따졌을 땐 그쪽이 더
있고 그리고 지금 원가를 넘어서서 왜
대기업 밸류체인이 주목을 받냐면
공장에다 넣을 수 있잖아요. 지금
필요한 건 움직임의 데이터입니다.
>> 데이터를 쌓을 수 있는 기업이어야
지금 전략을 그니까 갑어치를 비싸게
받을 수 있어요. 이제 시작하는
사업이기 때문에. 근데 현대 LG 다
본인들의 공장을 갖고 있잖아요.
거기다 넣어서 그 데이터를 비디아든
구글이든 딥마인드든 거기다가 팔 수
있다. 이런 기대도 있습니다.
>> 네. 좋습니다. 어쨌든 우리 한국
기업들 어 진짜 응원드리고 어 잘돼야
됩니다. 그러면서
>> 서로 싸우지 않았으면 좋겠어요. 어
같이 어 이렇게 시너지 힘을 합쳐서
같이 하고 어 함께 갔으면 좋겠다.
어 그리고 경쟁하면서 건설적인 경쟁을
하면서 네
>> 대한민국 기업들 정말 대단합니다.
>> 네. 제가 그 수출입 동양 보도자료
말씀드렸잖아요. 조회수가
2,500으로 들어요.
>> 아
>> 아니요. 너무 적어요.
>> 한 많이 돼야지.
여러분이 수출이 다시 한번
말씀드리지만 동영상은 꼭이 여러분
읽어 보세요.
>> 2,752회입니다. 현재
>> 예. 너무 재밌고 아 지금 한국의
기업들이 너무 잘하고 있다. 또
응원도 하면서 읽어 보시면 되게
재밌습니다.
>> 그리고 저 한 가지만 얘기해도요.
지금 제가 엔비디아 젠슨의 키노트
연설 틀어 놓고 있잖아요. 거기 현재
동시 접촉자 수가
29,000명이거든요.
>> 저희 몇 명이게요?
>> 아 지금
>> 아 경쟁합니까? 네명.
>> 지금 현재 97천
700명 정도 됩니다.
>> 여러분 얼마 안 남았어. 만오시면
10만이에요.
>> 잠깐만
>> 잠깐만. 우리 지금
>> 내가 이럴 때가 아니야.
>> 이럴 때가 아니야. 옆에 있는 동료
핸드폰 키셔야. 지금 오늘 넘어야
넘을 것 같아요.
>> 맞아요. 오늘 해야 돼. 오늘.
>> 네.
>> 여러분 카톡 전달해 드릴 거냐?
그러면 카톡에서 이게 뭐지? 갖고
잠깐 클릭할 거 아니야?
>> 예. 우리 링크를 뿌리세요.
카톡에다가.
>> 링크를 카톡에다 딱 뿌리면
어떻게해요? 잠깐 클릭할 거 아니야?
안도 그거 딱 들어올 거 아니에요,
여러분.
>> 오늘 10만 원 한번가 봅니다.
>> 10만 한번가 봅니다.
이렇게 정리해 보도록 하겠고요.
마지막 뉴스. 네. 가운전선 현재
주가가 13%대 급등하고 있고요.
LS 마린 솔루션, LS 같은 종목들
오랜만에 56, 6% 이상의 강세를
보여주고 있습니다. 전력 설비 그리고
변합기 관련해서 LS 일렉트릭도
13% 대급등, 효성 중고업 5%
이상의 강세. HD 현대 엘
일렉트릭도 3% 이상의 강세로
108만 원 지나가고 있는데요.
가운전선이 또 여러 가지 수주를
따냈다라고 합니다. 가운전선은 LS
전선의 자회사입니다. 이전에 메타를
고객사로 확보했는데 구글과 아마존에
AI 센터 부품을 수주했다라고
하고요. 올해 누적 수주가 최대
6조원에 달할 것이다라고 하면서
오르는데 제가 사실이 뉴스를 가져온
이유가 있습니다. 왜냐면 효성중공업
그리고 뭐 하여튼 전력 설비 관련된
종목들이 삼성전자 SK 하이닉스
레버리지 ETF 상장되고 나서
그때부터 꺾이기 시작했어요.
그래서맞네. 아니 제가 아무리 찾아도
뭔가가 없는 거예요. 아 이거는 어
수익이 많이 난 쪽에서 이제 차익시
잠깐만
>> 저희가 10만을 넘었습니다. 습니다.
야 자 이제 그만하겠습니다.
>> 황 다했다 됐다.
>> 다했다 이제 저희가 신만하면
그만하려고 그랬어요.
>> 즐거웠고요. 네
>> 여러분 저희도 이제 돈 좀 벌러
가겠습니다. 돈이 안 돼.
아, 여러분 진심으로 감사합니다.
아, 여러분 이거는 근데한 겁니다.
사실
>> 저희가 겸손해야 될 건음
이건 시장 덕이다. 그리고 여러분
덕이다라는 생각 갖고 있고요.
여러분의 함께 해주셔서 너무
감사합니다.
>> 그 감동적인 사진들 많잖아요. 그 한
번 더 보여 주실래요? 그러니까
최근에 또 들어온 사진 두 개 말고
한 다섯 여섯 개 들어온 거 있던데.
그것처럼 여러분들이
이거 이런 사진도 있었고 막 다섯
여섯 개 틀어 계신 분들
계시더라고요. 그래서 여러분들이 함께
해 주셔서 너무 감사하고 저희는 정말
어 여러분들이 많이 봐 주셔서이 힘을
갖고
>> 영향력 있는 일을 해보고 싶어요.
그래서 그 영향력이 나쁜 영향력이
아니라 선한 영향력.
>> 최근에도 저희가 기부 방송을
했잖아요. 이틀 만에 1억 원을
모았습니다.
>> 예. 대단하죠. 네. 어, 전
여러분과 함께 저희들은 여러분과 함께
그 영향력을 좋은 곳에 쓰도록
하겠습니다. 여러분 함께 해주셔서
너무 감사하고요.
>> 자, 근데 문제는 뭐냐? 이게 1일
천하가 돼서 안 된다. 여러분 계속
우리가 함께 노력하셔야 됩니다.
>> 네, 맞습니다.
>> 네. 너무 감사드리고 다시 뉴스로가
볼게요.
>> 네. 그 일단은 시장 분위기가 워낙
좋아서 그렇다라고
체크해 보도록 하겠고요. 말씀드린
대로 삼성전자 SK 하이닉스의 두 배
레버리지 상품이 딱 상장이 되고
그날부터 전력 설비 관련된 종목들이
꺾이기 시작했습니다.
>> 그렇죠. 아, 이게 사실 이유가
있을게 없는데 싶어서 고민을 해 본
결과 저의 그냥 저의 짧은 식견으로는
삼성전자 SK닉스 레버리지를 사고
싶은데 사실 현금이 많이 없으실
거잖아요. 그럼 수익이 되게 많이
나셨을 거예요. 전력 설비는. 그래서
그거를 팔고 넘어가셨나라는
고민이 조금 되더라고요.
>> 어, 여튼 그래서 그 오늘은 좀
그동안의 하락분을 반납해 내고 있다
이렇게 보시면 되네요. 네. 네. 그
사실은 이제 전력 관련해서는 AI
생태계에서 가장 중요한 병목으로
생각이 되기 때문에 또는 그 병목의
위치 중에서도 어쩌면 제일 앞단에
있다라고 하는 긍정적인 보고서도 많고
해서
>> 뭐 문제 없다 이렇게 이제 판단하셔도
좋았을 법했는데 최근에 조금
부진했어요. 부전의 이유가 이제 여러
개가 있는데 예를 들어서는 이제
미국에서 나온 한 보고서가 아
생각보다 정전력 관련한 수요가 부족은
한데 부족은 하기 때문에
>> 뭐 업항이 나빠질거다 뭐 그런 건
전혀 아니지만
>> 그 소위 말하는 이제 부족의 양
쇼티지가 생각보다는
>> 옛날에 예를 들면은 어 100만큼
부족할 거야라고 했던게 아니 한
50만큼 부족할 걸 요렇게 해서 조금
낮추는 보고가 있었어요. 그래도
부족은 부족이거든요. 네다
조금 주춤했다라는 해석도 좀 있고요.
한편으로 이제이 대장격이라고 할 수
있는 LS 쪽에서 공시 관련한 소동이
좀 있었어요. 조금 짜증나는 국면에
조금 찬물을 좀 부었죠. 사실 이제
별거 아닐 수도 있는데 그거 좀 잠깐
예네.
>> 어. 네. 네.
>> 그 공시 부분이 잘못 기재가 돼가지고
아마
>> 억단위랑 백단위를 헷갈려서 그런 거
같다라고 합니다. 근데 그
티라유텍이라고 그 LS의 자회사 중에
하나의 문제였고요. 그렇기 때문에
LS 일렉트릭의 누적 수주에는 큰
영향은 없다라고 정리할 수 있겠음.
네. 그런데 일단 음
>> 그래도이 믿음이신가
>> 예 그래도 이제 어떻게 단위를 틀리냐
이래 가지고 좀 시장에서 좀 짜증이
났죠. 그게 회사마다 이제 공시
담당자가 있어요. 그래서 공시를 낼
때 숫자를 계속 보고 그리고 공시가
복잡한게 아니거든. 네.
>> 제가 볼 때 이유가 뭘까? 어 뭔가
좀 술 챘나?
어 술이 덜 깼나?
>> 우리처럼요?네
네.
>> 아무튼 그런 어떤 그 크고 작은
약간의 일단 노이즈가 있는 상황에서
이제 권행님 말씀처럼음
>> 반도체 관련해서 수급을 좀 당기는에
이슈가 생기다 보니까
>> 약간 이제에 팔고 넘어가고 팔고
넘어가는 뭐 순남매 그림이 좀
있었는데 오늘부로 그래도 조금
그동안의 하락을 이제 멈추면서 잠깐
올라가는 이런 모습을 보여낸다.
그래서 요런 어떤 흐름들 시장의
흐름들을 잘 짚어 주신 거 같아요.
네.
>> 네.
감사합니다. 오늘 뭐 시장의 변동성도
크고 또 상승하고 있기 때문에 관련된
뉴스를 많이 정리해 봤고요.
>> 네.
>> 음. 이제 두 번째 코너로 가보도록
하겠습니다.
>> 예. 저희 두 번째 시간은음 저하고
그리고 박수 대표의 생각을 나눠보는
시간입니다. 오늘은 그동안 미뤄왔던
시동 생각을 좀 듣도록 하겠습니다.
>> 네. 시간이 뭐 여유가 없기 때문에
>> 일부러 조금 주는 거예요.
>> 말 많을까 봐.
>> 맞아요. 정확해요. 시간 많으면
부담스러워요. 안쪽은 많이 해야 될
것 같고. 그래서 예. 시간에 맞춰서
짧게 설명드리면요.이 맥락을 좀
이해해 보셔야 될 것 같은데 좀 전에
우리가 얘기했어요. 대만은 왜
19배씩이나 비싼 값으로 쳐 주고
한국은 왜 일곱 배 여덟 배밖에 안
쳐 줘. 우리가 돈을 더 많이
버는데라고 할 때
>> 굳이 말하자면 시장의 가치이가
>> 있어요. 얘네들은 그렇게 쳐 줘도
돼. 음.
하고 왔음에도 불구하고 야 이제
우리가 어 더 어 인도도 이겨야지
시총으로 그리고 어 더 높은 값으로
우리가 재값을 받아야지라고 할 때
여전히 중요한게이 기업들은 열심히 돈
잘 벌고 일 잘하는 것도 중요하지만
시장을 지속적으로 개혁해야 되거든요.
근데 지금 뭐 선거도 있고
등등등해서이 부분에 관한 동력이 다소
다소는 지금 이제 좀 속강 상태
들어간 거 아니냐라고 말씀하시는데
이거를 멈춰선 안 된다. 이렇게 돈
잘 벌고 잘 벌 때 여기서 이제 더
고평가를 받기 위해서는이 부분에 관한
엔진을 꺼서는 안 된다. 이런 말씀
드리는 거예요.
>> 그게 이재명 대통령이 얘기한 주식
시장 정상입니다. 맞습니다. 예를
들어서 대만 같은 경우에는 배당
수익률이 1.7인데 우리는
0.9예요. 구해요. 그러니까 같은
돈을 한국과 일본 저 대만에 넣으면
배당 두 배를 받는다는 얘기고요.
>> 뭐 이런 식으로 비교하는 자료들은
많아요. 그니까 이제 우리 시장의
가치를 제도적으로 올리는데 우리가
힘쓰지 않으면
>> 어 시장을 정상화하기는 쉽지 않기
때문에이 부분을 계속 해야 된다라는
거고 그중에 오늘 말씀드린이 테마는
뭐냐면 중복 상장 문제입니다.
>> 어 이재명 대통령도 이제 지속적으로
어 예를 들면서 지적을 한게
그거예요.
내가 어 암소를
사서
>> 네
>> 잘 키워서 이제 송아지를 임신했는데
>> 딱 소가 딱 나오자마자 가져간다. 내
소 어어 다른 사람이 가져가가 가지고
저건 내 성아지야 이러고 가져간다.
이런 일이 생기면 누가 암소를
사겠느냐라고 하는 거거든요.
>> 바로 그거예요. 회사를 믿고 우리가
투자를 하고 그 회사의 실적과 함께
성장의 과실을 누리려고 하는데 갑자기
송아지를 만들어 가지고 예, 다른
사람이 이건 내소야 이러고 가져간다.
이런 일이 사실은 중복 상장이거든요.
이거를 계속 이게 계속되면은 우리가
지금 예를 들어 삼성전자가 아무리
실적이 좋아도 내일 자고 일어났더니
삼성전자를 쪼개니다. 뭐 이런 일이
생기면 어떡하냐? 음
이근자는중복상장금인데
이게 이제 본격적인 제도화에 앞서서
지금 현재 학계 의견, 업계 의견을
듣는 중입니다. 현재 그래서 지난주에
에
>> 7월 7월에 예 7월에 이제 지금
벌써 6월이거든요. 이제 한 달
뒤면은 중복 상장 금지를 어떻게 할
것인가를 이제 정할 때가 돼요.
거래소 규정이 7월이면 바뀔 예정에
있습니다. 그러면 어떻게 바뀔 거냐를
놓고 지금 치열하게 논의 중요해요.이
부분에 관해서 우리 투자자분들도 또
어 많은 국민 여러분들도 관심을 가져
주셔야 돼요. 잘 결정이 될 수
있도록. 근데 지금 어떤 식으로
입장이 부딪히고 있냐면
>> 중복 상장 금지해야지 원칙적으로 한
회사에 상장이 돼 있으면 모든 이익이
그 회사에 남겨져 있어야 돼라고 하는
주장이 예. 특히 이제 우리 같은
이제 투자업계에서는 지금 현재 그
주장을 하고 있어요. 반면에 아니야.
그렇게 되다 보면 기업들이 자금
조달도 힘들어질 거고
어 특히 이제 법적 규제를 이렇게
강하게 해서는 안 돼라고 하는 반대
의견이 지금 치열하게 부딪히고 있는
중이에요.
>> 자 그래서 어 다음 달 시행을 앞두고
제가 이제 자세히는 소개해 드리려고
그랬는데 시간이 없으니까이 부분에
관한 논의가 지금 치열하게 전개되고
있다. 그래서 우리 투자자분들이 뭐
예전에 뭐 금투 논란이라든지 이런
것처럼 관심을 가져 주셔야 지금부터
한 달이 잘 지나서 7월에 제대로
이제 제도가 될 수 있다라는
말씀드리고요.
>> 중요합니다. 저런 제도들이 제대로 또
도입되면 또 다른음 상승의 이유가 또
될 수가 있는 거죠. 음.
>> 그 얘기입니다. 시간이 다 됐습니다.
>> 끝이요?
>> 끝입니다. 그래서
>> 근데 네
>> 우리 저 세미나요.
>> 우리는 왜 안 부르는 거예요?
>> 왜 안 부르는 거야?
진짜 어 큰 소리 친다고 안 부르나?
>> 앞으로 앞으로 청와대라든지
거래소라든지 이런 쪽에서 이런 중요한
세미나 할 때 우리 셋도 좀 불러
줘요.
>> 그 근데
>> 구경 좀 가자.
>> 근데 여러분 저희가 장점이 있습니다.
뭐냐면 싸요.
>> 거의 무료로 갑니다. 예. 무료로.
저희는 데일을 따르기 때문에 예.
그렇죠. 그죠.
>> 예. 우리 시동 생각 들어봤고요.
>> 네. 사실 전 2026년 우리 하반기
대한민국의 주식시장에서이 이슈가 가장
중요하다고 봐요. 주식시장 정상화에
대한 여러 가지 논의들이 앞으로
많아질 텐데 뭐 법도 상법 4차
계정도 그렇고 관련해서 저희가 계속
여러분과 함께 말씀을 나눠 보도록
하겠습니다.
>> 네.
>> 1시가 가까이 오는데 오늘 10만이
넘었습니다. 아 너무 다시 한번
감사드리고요.
>> 어 저희가 마무리하면서 여러분들의 또
사연을 있는 시간을에 가져오도록
하겠습니다.
>> 네. 어 일단 첫 번째 사연은 우리
권다영커 님이 한번 읽어 주세요.
>> 네.
꾸릉 님께서네 담겨 주신 댓글입니다.
안녕하세요. 두 분 덕분에 용기를
내어서 올해부터 적지만 쟁여둔 돈으로
주식 투자를 시작한 40대
주부입니다. 조금씩 불어나는 수익을
보면 기쁘도 기쁘고 신기하면서도
한편으로론 1은 넘은 나이에도 여전히
생계를 위해 병원 청소일를 하시는
친정 엄마가 늘 마음이 쓰였어요.
평생 노동만으로 성실히 접금만
모으시다 보니 형편은 늘
제자리셨거든요.
더 늦으면 안 되겠다 싶어서 조심슬레
엄마에게 투자를 권했고 엄마는 의외로
선뜻 응하셨어요.
딸, 엄마는 그런 거 잘 모르잖아.
평생 은행에 넣는 것밖에 몰랐지.이
이 말씀이 너무 마음 아팠습니다. 혹
엄마 돈을 잃을까 봐 두렵고 걱정했던
마음을 이제 내려놓고 엄마의 편안한
노후를 위해 조금이라도 도움드리고
싶어요. 조금이라도 일찍 말씀드릴 걸
하는 후회와 안타까움도 큽니다.
지금도 늦지 않았겠죠? 제가 대신
계좌 관리를 해 드리는데 그저께
엄마의 천만 원이 며칠 사이만 원
수익이 나서 화면을 캡처해서 보내
드렸더니 그것도 너무 좋아하시네요.
행복합니다.
그리고 선한 영향력을 베푸시는 귀한
새분께 정말 감사드립니다라고
남겨 주셨습니다.
>> 네. 감사합니다. 귀한식 귀한 사연
어 전달해 주셔서 감사하고요. 제가
두 번째 또 이야기를 나눠 볼까
합니다. 유저샵 님께서 방송을 보고
남겨 주신 댓글입니다.
안녕하세요. 반도체 노동자의 건강과
인권 지킴이 반올림입니다.
방송에서 반올림 얘기해 주시고 후원해
주신 분 사연까지 소개해 주신 덕분에
많은 분들이 후원해 주셨습니다. 안
그래도 재작년 후원 행사로 모은 돈이
소진되어 가고 있어서 다시 후원
행사를 준비하던 중이었는데 하루 만에
열분이 후원해 주셨습니다. 후원해
주신 모든 분들께 진심으로
감사드립니다. 한국에서 반도체 직업
직업병 문제가 많이 알려져서 환경이
개선되어 왔지만 여전히 질병과 죽음은
계속되고 있습니다. 환경 개선에도
양극화가 있어서 위험한 일들이 점점
더 낮고 보이지 않는 곳으로 옮겨가고
있습니다. 삼성전자와 SK 하이닉스
공장에서 일하는 노동자의 25%에서
30%가 협력 업체 노동자이고
이분들이 가장 위험한 일들을 담당하고
있습니다. 외부협 외부 협력 업체
노동자들도 마찬가지고요. 반도체
수익이 이분들에게도 돌아가야 한다고
생각합니다. 아가 반도체에 엄청난
수익 중 일부는 위험한 작업 환경을
개선하는데 쓰이면 좋겠습니다. 일하다
병든 노동자들을 위해서도 쓰이길
바라고요. 반올님은 아픈 노동자들을
위해 안전한 일터를 위해 계속
노력하겠습니다.
반올림의 활동에도 많은 관심을
부탁드립니다. 감사합니다.
어, 여러분, 오늘 또 사연은 음,
우리 어머니께서 44만 원을 수익을
얻었다는 사연이 예, 저희가
읽었습니다. 지금 주식 시장이 이렇게
오르니까 나 뭐 수십억 벌었어, 억
벌었어, 몇 천만 원 벌었어. 이런
분들 많으세요. 그런데 저는 오늘이
44만 원이 너무 감동스럽게
다가왔습니다. 어쩌면
어 어쩌면 그 되게 작은 금액일 수도
있겠지만 누군가에는 굉장히 큰 금액일
겁니다. 이런 분들과 우리가 또
함께하고 싶습니다.음
그리고 저희가 한번 소개시켜 드린
적이 있죠. 반올님입니다. 반도체
노동자의 건강과 인권 지킴이입니다.
어 저희가 소개시켜 드린 이후로 또
몇 분이 후원행 후원에 또 참여해
주셨다고 해요. 여러분들이에 너무
감사드린 말씀을 또 드리고 12시에
만나는이 일을 하고 싶습니다. 어,
소박한 그리고 작은 수익을 함께
여러분들과 함께 하고 싶고 두 번째는
세상에 관심 없는 부분을 알려 드리고
우리가 또 함께 지원하고 어, 먼
것을 바라보는 그런 일들을 해 보도록
하겠습니다. 여러분, 너무 귀한 시간
또 함께 해 주셔서 감사하고요. 오늘
저희가이 마음을 잊지 않도록
하겠습니다. 6월 1일입니다. 6월
1일 날 여러분들이 이렇게 어 달성해
주신 그 10만의 기록과 그 정성과
마음을 잊지 않도록 하겠습니다.
열심히 더 하도록 하겠습니다. 내일
또 신나게 뵙도록 하겠습니다.
고맙습니다.
>> 감사합니다.
>> 안녕.
>> 20263 지방 선거 개표 방송.
겸손이 힘들다. 개표공장 민심온이
방송됩니다.
>> 누가 웃고 누가 무너질 것인가? 숫자
뒤에 숨은 민심의 흐름. 가장 빠르고
가장 깊게 읽겠습니다. 전국 곳곳에서
올라오는 개표 상황과 판세를 뒤흔드는
마지막 변수까지 6월 3일 오후
4시부터 자전까지 가장 뜨거운
현장으로 함께하시죠. 6363
지방선거 경민들과 대표공부장 민심
많은 시청 바랍니다.
>> 개표 방송
>> 딴 데서 합니까?
เฮ